let's begin with the chicago bears we
explained yesterday that coach matt nagy
was going to make a decision last night
along with his offensive coaching staff
as to who the quarterback would be the
decision has been made here is matt nagy
announcing it earlier today
got up this morning and went through the
tape and and at the end of it we decided
that we're going to start nick foles uh
as a starter uh against indianapolis so
um both quarterbacks are aware of that
uh i know it's you know for us
it's never easy um when you go into
these type of situations i want to
credit both of those guys
in in yesterday's situation for being um
really supportive of each other uh this
whole time
uh even as hard as that was for mitch to
to be told that he's uh he's you know
nick's going to go in and play
um
mitch was to his credit was just an
awesome supporter of
of nick
that game and he told he flat out told
nick i'm gonna have your back just like
you've had mine uh from from the start i
think that that speaks to who he is
as well with him speaking to all you
guys after uh after the game which he
doesn't have to do and he did it i think
that speaks volumes to mitch and who he
is as a person so
um
you know we're still going to support
each other as we move forward here we
have a healthy quarterback room and
we're just looking forward to prepping
here uh against the
is colts shireen when you think about it
take a step back
the bears start two-and-oh mitch
trubisky who was named the starter eight
days or nine days before the start of
the regular season leads the team back
from a 17 point second half deficit
against the lions
they hold off the giants yeah they
probably let the giants back into a game
that they shouldn't have but they're 2-0
they're 2-0 and they're down 16 points
in the second half against a team that
notoriously blows leads
and mitch trubisky did not through 10
quarters of football build off up and up
enough equity to hold on to the job it's
it's astounding when you think about it
i mean if there was going to be a
benching of trubisky after three games
we assume they'd at least be one and two
maybe owen three it's it's uh it's
jarring when you think about it it makes
you wonder why trubisky had the job in
the first place
well and that's the biggest surprise
mike was that he won the job in the
first place and i think if there had
been a regular off-season where they got
the on-field work and nick foles had
learned the offense fully i think nick
foles would have come out of that with
the starting job and i think that they
just felt uncomfortable with foals and
his knowledge of the offense now they
kept saying oh it's like riding a bike
for him he's been under maggie before
but then when all was said and done and
they named mitchell trubisky as a
starter if they went back to well nick
doesn't know the offense well enough he
needs more time in it apparently he
knows it well enough because he played
really good in the fourth quarter i
would say this i think nick foles is
probably if not the best backup in nfl
history
right there with earl morrell and maybe
some other guys that you could name
now he hasn't made a lot of starts and i
think that's the big question mark for
him he's never started more than 11
games in a season
yeah and look there aren't many backup
quarterbacks that ever won the super
bowl mvp award if any and
uh of jeff hostetler is the only one
that comes and was he even the mvp of
that game no it was otis anderson
because hostile didn't do all that much
in super bowl 25. so uh
it's just so strange they acquire nick
foles we assume nick foles is going to
be the guy it's just a matter of time
it's just a matter of checking the boxes
and trubisky outperformed him apparently
dramatically in training camp and sims
and i were talking about this today
under the assumption that foals would
get the nod apparently since the moment
trubisky became the starter foal's
performing better
in practice maybe trubisky not
performing as well but something clicked
something happened something went down
behind the scenes
to cause matt nagy to have what he
described to me yesterday as that gut
feeling that the time had come to flip
from trubisky to falls because again
it's the falcons it's the team that's
notorious for blowing leads and if you
let trubisky hang in there and if
trubisky pulls that one off
you're giving him an even greater
confidence boost instead he's now thrown
under the bus and that's the coach's
prerogative but from the standpoint of
his own confidence
he's not going to build that back until
foles either gets injured or gets
benched and if i had to pick between the
two i'd say injury we have to keep that
on the radar screen he took a big hit
yesterday on the game-winning touchdown
pass he took a big hit on the first
touchdown pass he threw as a member of
the jaguars last year he broke a
collarbone he's not a big thick guy that
is going to end up withstanding that
kind of of a pounding so trubisky better
stay ready and they better do what they
can to keep him
at the right
mindset so he can come in and perform
because they're probably going to need
him at some point over the next 13 games
yeah they probably are mike and it was a
good time to ch if you're going to make
that change you made it in the game and
you knew when you made it in a game you
don't make it in a game and that backup
comes in and leads you to a victory and
then you're going to go back to the
other guy that's just that wasn't going
to happen i think we all knew that i
think mitchell trubisky probably knew
that yesterday as he's standing there on
the sideline and nick foles is leading
them back but they're through the soft
part of their schedule i mean these were
three games that were winnable and they
won them somehow some way they made it
harder probably than it should have been
but they won these games and so now they
get in the meat of their schedule and it
was
the right time as matt nagy said that
gut feeling because the schedule is
going to get harder and nick foles is
that guy probably to lead them at least
until he gets hurt i think this is going
to be his job mitchell trubisky might
have played his last game in chicago
that is that is a fact unless foles gets
hurt
and now he told me last night he does
not want to go back and forth which was
the strongest clue i believe that it was
going to be false because
if you just had a gut feeling that
caused you to remove mitchell trubisky
the chances of trubisky being the guy
you put back in with the mandate that
you're the guy no more gut feelings
that's slim he knows that foals is the
guy he's known that foals is the guy
there's a story out there that
may never be told because frankly we may
not care about it if the bears go down
the drain here but if they end up being
a playoff team and end up having some
success in the postseason like nick
foles teams have had in the past there's
a hell of a story as to why he wasn't
the week one and week two starter
because maybe he should have been
and at this point it doesn't matter
because you're right he is until further
notice and i think the only way trubisky
is back on the field for the bears is if
foles gets injured or if they come up
with some sort of specialty package
where he's almost like a taste some hill
type of a figure we're going to talk
about tyson hill coming up later in the
show but
sims and i spit bald about that in the
off season the possibility that foles is
a starter you still find a way to get
trubisky onto the field because he's
extremely athletic
yeah he is athletic he can make plays i
went and looked at his stats and
the wins the losses the all the stats
they're they're okay i mean they're not
great but they're okay and and he's
going to be good enough that somebody's
going to give him a job next year but
he's also good enough that he can help
you this year even if it's as your
backup quarterback he can help you this
year and the bears think they have a
really good team they think they have as
good a team as they had a couple years
ago and they should have
should have won that playoff game
against the eagles if not for the clank
off the off the goal post
on the field goal so they think they
have a good team so he's he needs to be
ready he needs to stay involved i think
he has a really good mindset that's
what's probably impressed me more about
him than anything else that he's done on
the field
and the bottom line is this assuming
that foles stays healthy on sunday
against the colts win or lose because
that's not an easy game for the bears 10
days from now thursday night football
super bowl 52 reunion and nfc central
reunion although
that's a lesser reunion than having nick
foles and tom brady on the field
together again prime time you know we're
paying the penance this week with
broncos jets we're getting the payoff
next week with buccaneers bears tom
brady and nick foles and a game that
that could have significant implications
for both teams if both teams continue
their winning ways but you're right the
easy part of the schedule is over now
and you've got games coming up against
the bucks the rams the saints the titans
they play the vikings twice they have to
go to green bay
so uh
bears uh 3-0 and we'll see where they go
from here
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports